believe it or not this iPad Pro is
currently charging without any wires at
all as you can see using a very unique
system which is the closest you can get
to Apple's Mac safe on an iPad it even
comes with a charging puck just like the
max save charger that you snap on no
plugging any cables in and it charges
just like that now this is all part of
the pita flow magnetic system by pitaka
which I don't know if you guys know or
not but we've shown off a lot of
different pataka products mainly because
of their carbon fiber real weave and now
they want to show off a couple of their
awesome products including their
charging stand which also supports
iPhones their mag easy case Pro and
their mag easy folio 2 which is
absolutely incredible so before I show
you guys how this charging system works
I want to show this off now as you guys
can tell the magazine folio 2 is
incredibly thin lightweight and very
portable and is built in with extremely
strong magnets and my favorite thing
about it is that it actually works with
their case Pro so you just snap it on
just like this with magnets and there
you go you're fully protected all around
and as soon as you're ready to use your
iPad you just flip open the folio to the
back super strong magnet so it doesn't
flop around at all which is very nice
and then you can start using the
built-in stand as you can see just fold
it over just like that it's very very
strong and sturdy for example if you're
using your apple pencil it is not moving
and shaking all over the place you could
do your drawing very very nice and you
can easily flip it over to portrait mode
just like this and same thing it is very
very strong and stable but there is a
secret to this as well right here on the
side is a hidden magnetic strap for your
apple pencil so for example you close it
stick your apple pencil on the charger
and Bam you magnetically strapped it in
it's not going anywhere and in terms of
the build quality and material this is
using a PU leather so it's very nice and
smooth it feels great and it doesn't
leave fingerprints all over it like a
lot of the other cases do and once again
I love that the case Pro is fully
compatible with the folio and this thing
is just so incredibly lightweight and
now I want to Pivot over to showing you
how the magnetic charging system works
as you can see on the back of the case
Pro you see this x with these pins now
the charger itself only has one line of
pins but that means you can connect it
any way you want it works either way it
doesn't have to be specific just drop it
on and it's going to charge now within
the case there's actually electrical
wires that go through this really nice
by the way carbon fiber super high
quality it goes through to the bottom
and as you can see it's sealed off and
it actually plugs in with a USBC cable
into the iPad Pro itself and of course
if you ever need to plug something else
in you just pull it back plug it in and
then when you're not using it there you
go and then same thing on the charging
stand as you can see we have those same
line of pins so you literally just drop
on your iPad and there you go it is now
charging and it gets even better because
this charging stand has a wide variety
of angles as you can see up and down but
watch this with one finger
I literally just switched to portrait
mode and guess what it keeps rotating
endlessly without disrupting the
magnetic charging which is absolutely
incredible and the thing that blows my
mind is that this charging system
supports 20 watt PD yes 20 watts faster
than Apple's Max save and right here we
actually have up to a 15 watt charger
which of course will support your air
pods your iPhone Android phone whatever
you have so there you guys go hopefully
you're as impressed as I am with
pataka's lineup of accessories for the
iPad Pro including the mag easy folio 2
the Mac easy case Pro and the charging
stand as well so you're gonna find links
down in the description below including
our own special coupon code max10 off to
get 10 off your order using the links
below thanks for watching this has been
vadine with Max Tech and we'll see you
in the next video
foreign